[Music]
hello everyone good morning and welcome
to fragments in an architecture
components world so over time there
fragment api's have kind of evolved and
as of the release of architecture
components a lot of people have been
asking us questions like sir how do all
these things fit together so hopefully
we'll be able to answer some of those
questions today but first just a little
bit of history like the fragment api's
go back to 2010 was when they were first
initially written 2011 when they hit a
little bit more widespread availability
and really it kind of comes down to the
idea that at the very beginning
everybody just kind of started with the
activity when you're writing an Android
app it was kind of your main method with
a life cycle it's the entry point to
your application from the system the
launcher will launch your activity you
get all the oncreate on start resume etc
events that you all know and love it'll
create views for you it creates the
window let gives you a place to inflate
your view hierarchy where you do most of
your UI work it binds the view content
from your app state or at least this is
where people tended to do it keep in
mind that this was fairly early on in
androids public lifecycle here everybody
kind of had this habit of piling
everything into one activity because
apps were a lot more simple than they
are today and of course you listen to UI
events and update that app state from
there as well so there are so many
incoming events it really kind of became
this plumbing exercise to try to break
it up yourself
so people ended up with these very
monolithic activities and then something
else happened to Android tablets kind of
became a thing so we kind of thought you
know how do you make a tablet UI well
you take one phone UI you take another
phone UI and you smack them together and
you have a tablet UI right I mean what
could go wrong
so we needed to answer this question of
how do I stick to phone you eyes
together and make sure that it still
works on a phone and fragments were kind
of our answer to this question
so as an example here this approach
actually worked pretty well for some
applications Gmail is a great example so
if you take a look here you have the
list of conversations to your current
conversation that you're taking a look
at and there's not a whole lot of
difference here between the the phone
version that you drill into versus
something that you can show side by side
in the two pane UI so fragments were
really designed to make sure that you
could do one thing and that was to allow
splitting up these huge activity classes
this was something that again we were
seeing the pain that developers were
feeling that their activity classes were
getting really big and hard to manage so
we wanted to see could we allow for you
to decouple some of the various things
that your activity classes are doing to
sort of relieve a little bit of that
pressure so that means that anything a
fragment can do or anything an activity
can do a fragment had to be able to do
too and that guided a whole lot of the
API design from the beginning so that
meant that you needed to have lifecycle
events that needed that meant that you
needed to be able to manage a view
hierarchy it meant that you needed to be
able to deal with saved instance state
so packaging everything up into a bundle
or parcel bowls so that if your
application got killed in the background
you could restore from that in a clean
way and other things as well like non
configuration instance object passing
and that's always kind of a mouthful but
I mean this is kind of the way that you
can pass any old object back and forth
across a configuration change that
doesn't actually kill your process back
stacks were another really big one
because suddenly if you were dealing
with a single activity where you were
navigating between fragments we wanted
to make sure that we preserved that same
back stack behavior that you're used to
from just calling start activity from
spring to screen so along the way we
asked question can we fix some other
api's that were really kind of a pain in
the neck in Android to use on retained
on configuration instance again kind of
a mouthful this method kind of had some
problems because you've only got one
object that you could pass from activity
instance to activity instance we didn't
give you any easy or standardized way to
multiplex diff
objects together so for example if you
were composing multiple libraries we
didn't give you a whole lot of help this
was all boilerplate that you had to
write yourself activity show dialog does
anybody remember this a few people okay
please forget it immediately please
please forget it yeah so this was
essentially a way to get the activity
itself to sort of do something that we
knew was was missing and kind of a pain
in the neck this allowed you to make the
activity on the other side after a
configuration change the new instance of
your activity reshow what is
semantically the same dialogue we also
had this thing local activity manager
tab host does anybody remember this one
wow that is a lot more hands than I
thought I would see so some of you might
remember this from for example the
original dialer and contacts app back in
kind of the Android 2.0 days and as
you've swapped between tabs between the
the normal number pad and your contact
list or call log etc those were actually
separate activities showing within a
smaller window within an activity this
idea of nesting activities was something
that we started offering very early it
had a lot of other issues though
activities made a whole lot of promises
that local activity manager had a lot of
trouble trying to uphold so we wanted to
try and tighten that interface a little
bit better for something composable like
fragments that would be able to do the
same thing but with a little bit more
expected behavior right so this whole
idea of being able to break up your
activity and make it into kind of
composable pieces you know we have this
giant monoliths of an activity and you
know there's other methods of kind of
factoring it out into different pieces
but for fragments basically approach was
you move that loosely related code right
those view and all of the state around
that view into a separate fragment and
you basically just keep doing this until
you've kind of segmented out your
activity into something that looks
slightly more reasonable right you may
have a couple of fragments in here that
kind of have their own specific
requirements and their own specific UI
and your activity just becomes more of a
show
for this but soon after we started
getting into this and when it came up to
around jellybean people were like but
this isn't enough like what if one of my
fragments has a viewpager in it that
also has fragments as each one of its
pages so we get into this alright well
now let's break up the fragments into
smaller pieces so of course you know the
only way well if fragments aren't enough
then you just add more fragments in this
case child fragments became a thing so
now each one of these fragments could
then be broken up into smaller pieces so
this allowed us to kind of again kind of
D couple things and we built a lot of
code around trying to make this nested
state work really well to varying levels
of degree of success but it's gotten a
lot better over time so with these
things in mind every one of those
fragments whether it's a small thing
just managing a view or if it's a
retained instance fragment every single
one of these fragments give you life
high cycle hooks every single one of
them has back stack management
associated with them every single one of
them has a retained object that I can do
across configuration changes and all of
them are stored stateful e in your
fragment manager that means that the
existence of that fragment is actually
part of the state of your app so when
your app dies and comes back that
existence in the fragment manager is
actually a really important part that at
least from fragments perspective that
we're going to do on your behalf and of
course they all have their own ability
to have a view subtree so that piece of
your UI that they manage themselves and
of course we also allow things like
fragments being inflatable and put right
into your XML files and be able to reuse
them across multiple layouts and again
this is also kind of hooking into these
same processes but the biggest issue we
found
is that all these fragments do all of
these things at once whether you want
them to or not and most of the time
you're only actually using one or two of
these things and not the full 16 things
that fragments do that you get as kind
of a bundle of deal so that means that
some of these things like the stateful
restoration means you have a lot of
patterns that look like this where you
have to make sure that the fragment
manager is in the right state so in this
case we're actually checking well
alright is there no saved instance state
ie are we in a fresh run of this
activity and oh now I need to add my
fragment to my layout so if you've ever
gotten this approach where you have one
fragment over another one yeah this is
this kind of state full restoration
actually being something that was a
useful bit but at the same point like
maybe not exactly what you were
expecting or something that you even
wanted in some cases but for fragments
you kind of got all of them together in
a package deal but last year we kind of
took a more holistic approach to how we
do api's and this really kind of started
with a lot of the work we did on
architecture components so all of the
architecture components have really
tried to focus in on doing one thing
well rather than being kind of the
kitchen sink kind of approach so for
example lifecycle observers the ability
to have life cycle and that onresume on
start as kind of a piece that is
completely independent from other things
something that you can register just if
you care about life cycle
similarly for view model we created a
new primitive a new object specifically
for that kind of retained instance state
across configuration changes and of
course this year just yesterday we
announced a new navigation architecture
component kind of working at the a much
higher level architecture on how you
bill
your UI and put these things together
and really trying to tackle just the
specific problem of how do you move from
one screen to the next screen so all
these things were kind of really focused
on doing one thing well and we're trying
to bring a lot of that to fragments but
that means that you know we kind of have
a lot of legacy to go along with that
that's right
so part of this is that fragments were
really designed around this idea of very
loose dependencies and loose guarantees
about some of the interaction between
them so another kind of quiz for the
audience how many of you know the answer
to this question does a child fragments
oncreate method run before or after its
parents oncreate method how many of you
are confident that you know the answer
not a whole lot I'm gonna give you no
idea about no how many of you thought
you knew the answer before I asked the
question and then you started
questioning yourself yeah okay I'll
admit that sometimes I have to
double-check this as well because the
answer really kind of depends on whether
the parent is an activity or if the
parents of fragment what version are you
running on are you talking about Android
app dot fragments or the support library
fragments because the answer has been
different over time we've changed this
around and if you were trying to design
a fragment that worked across all
versions of Android that was writing to
the framework fragments you had to deal
with these rules kind of changing out
from under you a little bit you couldn't
count on anything so one of the things
that we allowed for here with lifecycle
observers is that we really wanted to
give a very strict ordering of the
callbacks you have a strict lastin
first-out callback ordering for all
lifecycle observers in any given
lifecycle this is important because it
means that you can set up dependencies
between lifecycle observers and use
lifecycle observers as the
implementation details of a particular
activity instance or fragment instance
as the case may be you can make sure to
maintain guarantees between certain
lifecycle events so that any other
lifecycle observers that other libraries
you may be using can take advantage of
those guarantees that you've configured
lifecycle observers are created by you
we don't try to recreate them via
reflection which means that you can use
any sort of creation pattern that you
may find useful within your app so this
seems like a really small thing but it
was a big piece of feedback that we got
with fragments the implication of that
though is that you no longer get
stateful restoration by the system now
again in some cases this is exactly what
you want you want to make sure that you
have a single control flow path as
you're configuring your lifecycle
observers you don't want to be checking
hey is my instant state going to bring
this back for me I don't want to end up
with two of these things so on and so
forth right so one of these really
common patterns that we saw a lot of app
developers using is actually a headless
fragment a fragment without a UI that
was used basically only to receive on
start on stop life cycle events so for a
lot of these kind of approaches
lifecycle observers are going to give
you the same kind of API service but
with a lot smaller kind of API that you
don't actually need all of the things of
fragment so what does this actually look
like you might have just a simple life
cycle observer that does analytics calls
and your analytics library might want on
start on stop of a particular lifecycle
so the thing here is that this is an
independent piece from fragments from
activities now that has a couple of
super important things in that one you
can test it independently you don't have
to spin up the whole world just to test
this piece you can test it in isolation
also because you can create this
observer you can use whatever methods
you want if you want to use an
dependency injection kind of model and
inject in your dependencies like that is
really easy to do in this model rather
than trying to do it in the scope of an
activity or fragment or doing that kind
of thing so this gives you a lot more
power to kind of split out this into a
composable piece so if you're building a
library
you can just use this same lifecycle
observer across all of your fragments or
all of your activities and not have to
duplicate that data or worry about like
okay well what state is my instance data
and you can just always say add the
observer and we're done there's no more
no more work you need to do here so this
offers a lot simpler alternative for
this specific use case we've got some
glowing slides to get there
okay so retained instance fragments
we're really designed to outlive an
activity these were basically just a
setter on a fragment to say hey retain
my instance state across across
configuration changes this was a pretty
useful thing because it meant that you
could save handles to expensive data or
operations if you start some sort of
query that might take a little bit to
complete you don't want to restart that
just because somebody rotated the screen
or something got resized it meant that
you could reconnect to these same
operations after that configuration
change but really please don't do UI
during this this was another one of
those kind of headache pain point sorts
of things fragments do everything all at
once but these were two things that just
really did not taste great together the
reasoning for this is of course that
views hold on to the context that
created them well what context do you
use to create views most of the time
well it ends up being the activity you
don't want to hold on to a reference to
an old activity after a configuration
change ended up using the same views now
technically it's possible to do this
right you can go ahead and drop all your
references in ondestroy view recreate
the view after after you come around the
other side this was way too difficult to
get right all the time just because
references to these views end up leaking
out and getting everywhere no matter
what you try to do so this was something
that was it was really just kind of a
foot gun waiting - waiting to hurt
people but of course in the architecture
component world there's a different
solution for this retained instance
pattern and that comes in the model of
view models so this was kind of a brand
new class and to be honest the class
doesn't really do a whole lot it's how
it connects to the overall system so
instead of being again part of the
fragment api's this is a more
general-purpose thing something that you
can attach to any activity or any
fragment or any view model store owner
if you're building your own framework
and the main thing that's different here
just kind of like the lifecycle
observers is that we are not the owner
of creating those objects so by default
we provide a factory that just creates a
new instance or creates a new instance
and attaches your application context to
it but at the same point this is a super
powerful hook for again kind of adding
in those extra dependencies so if you're
using dependency injection like again
you have kind of the hooks you need to
hook into the view model creation and
pass those in just as a constructor
parameter right there really doesn't
need to be a more complicated structure
than that so but you get into the same
problem of like okay well how do I
connect my UI and the other piece of the
puzzle here is a different architecture
component called live data and live data
is kind of all about a lifecycle aware
observer so in this model in this world
your view model is the one who's storing
the data right and it's the live data
that it has that it can then pass to the
activity or fragment as they get created
and recreated and that fragment or
activity can just observe the live data
that the view model owns so this model
kind of separates things out where
instead of it being the view model that
needs to hold on to a reference to views
the activity can then pull the
information out of the view model
so I think for a lot of use cases where
you're using a retained in some state
specifically to kind of store this
expensive data and do that kind of work
view models offer really good
alternative to retained instance
fragments so what's a super simple one
look like well in this case we're going
to use an Android view model so here we
get a reference to your application your
application context so this is really
useful if you're doing things like a
service locator kind of pattern but the
important thing here is that the view
model stores an instance of a live data
in this case I live data that has a list
of our fancy renamed expensive data
class now normally you'd put this in
line but slides are hard so here we're
using it and we're getting our data from
a room database a simple or database but
you can really get this data from
anywhere or set up kind of the correct
lifecycle events here so that your live
data can kind of get into the right
State but that means that your actual
fragments or activities don't need to
know where this data came from right
it's encapsulated in the view model and
again we're in the same thing where we
can now test this view model in
isolation we don't need to create
activities we don't need to create
fragments to get to this same view model
we can just use them in isolation and
make sure that all of the work we need
here to get our expensive data and make
sure that it's in the right State can
all be done kind of separate from the
actual UI pieces of the framework all
right so everybody's favorite topic when
it comes to the fragment API is fragment
transactions because this is a statement
that said by you know pretty much no one
ever
fragment transactions are asynchronous
by default if you call commit on a
fragment transaction then that ends up
getting posted for later and it'll occur
kind of on the next normal Handler pulse
of your main thread or if another life
cycle event is coming up we'll go ahead
and execute all the pending transactions
bring it to a consistent state before we
move to that next state now this
actually has a few benefits to it
believe it or not for as much as
everybody gets kind of frustrated about
it and the biggest one is that you don't
have any reentrant fragment operations
this means that if you end up
manipulating fragments within say the
oncreate of another fragment then you
don't start getting into a state where
you have a half initialized fragment
while you're waiting to bring another
fragment up to speed now this is a
source of countless bugs I think that it
was even just earlier this week last
week that we were helping developer
troubleshoot some other reentrant
behavior bugs that was coming from view
callbacks for example and this is the
sort of thing that is can be really
really subtle and the asynchronous
fragment transactions sidestep all of it
and that was kind of convenient the
drawbacks are of course that the
observed state at any given point in
time doesn't actually reflect any of the
queued transactions so this is a huge
problem this basically means that if one
piece of your code submits a fragment
transaction another piece of your code
tries to read something out of state
that that fragment would have set up for
you whether that's another view
hierarchy that would have gotten
attached to sort of a sub hierarchy of
your UI or whether that's just some data
about a pending operation say for one of
these retained instance fragments this
essentially means that you can't trust
anything about the current state of the
app it means that you can have various
data races just within the normal main
thread handler of your application we've
even seen people run into the issues of
sort of the the layered fragments on top
of one another because of this issue
because they were checking the fragment
manager to see hey what is my current UI
pain for example that's currently there
it said oh look nothing I don't have
anything to do let me go ahead and make
a new fragment transaction and stick
something there but there was already
something in flight so this was
something that was really kind of a pain
in the neck and everybody loved when the
commit now API was added because it lets
you do something right immediately as
long as you promise that you weren't
gonna do anything with your current
fragment manager as part of that
transaction but we kind of get to this
point where okay now we have all these
fragment transaction code in your app
and very subtle changes that you may not
pick up in a simple CL all of a sudden
are changing the whole behavior of your
app and we really took a look at this
and we said well like should you really
have to be writing all of these fragment
transactions by hand like for so many of
the use cases
we can do a little bit better here we
can do a lot better here especially for
the really common cases so we built
navigation brand new architecture
component that's really kind of focused
on that screen to screen transitions
between fragments or other UI pieces
because we really want to make it work
well with fragments fragments are a
really great way of getting access to
lifecycle observers and view models and
also you know being an owner of a view
and those are really kind of the main
pieces you need when you're trying to
build a good Android app at the same
point we realize there's a lot of things
that fragments do that we don't really
want you to have to deal with yourself
so one of the things with navigation
that we really focused on was actually
being able to take ownership of the back
stack make sure that the navigation
component can actually handle that back
stack for you whether using fragments
are using something else the ownership
of that backs that kind of lace with
navigation that gives us a lot more
flexibility and a lot more ability to
you know be a little bit more
prescriptive and a little bit more
opinionated on what is a good thing to
do and what's a not-so-great thing to do
and kind of give you a lot of the same
power of fragment transactions without
actually having to touch one with your
our hands because again we're trying to
make things so that you know you have
all of the power without necessarily the
headache and the problems that run
across some of the things that Adam
pointed out so we're gonna be talking in
detail about navigation tomorrow morning
at 8:30 I know you're all early risers
but I wanted to give you a little bit of
a preview kind of how simple this could
be so we actually offer a helper method
where if you want to click a button and
do a full-screen transition to another
fragment we have a create navigate
onclicklistener that literally just does
that just that all you need to do is
pass in the ID of one of those
destinations that you've set up in
navigation now this looks a little bit
magical so what is this actually doing
under the covers well really what it's
doing is it's using this nav controller
object and one of the things that I find
super useful about navigation is you can
actually find that nav controller from
any view or any fragment that's been
created by navigation so here we're
using a column extension which makes
this a lot easier if you're in the Javal
and it's just a static method but here
we can find from any view we're going to
say find nav controller and get an
instance of our nav controller and then
just call navigate and this navigate
call knows how to do fragment
transactions so our nav controller in
this case is set up with a fragment
navigator our own class that knows all
about the correct behavior of doing
fragment transactions and how to do all
of that work for you so that from your
codes perspective you can just call
navigate and we'll do the right thing
for you so obviously there's a lot more
here like if you want to pass arguments
like you can do a bundle approach we
also have a lot more things around that
specific case that we'll be talking
about tomorrow as well as well as
setting things like separate animations
and other objects in here so you have a
lot of the same power but
you can also make it really easy to use
and move a lot of the code that used to
be a fragment transaction that you'd
have to make really sure that you got
right into something that navigation can
understand and helpless
so Adam we've talked a lot of things
about why not fragments but this is kind
of a fragment talk right so what why
that's why everyone's here yeah
so why fragments its 2018 it is 2018 so
what what are fragments still good for
after we've sort of carved off some of
these other extension points so before
we talk about that I think it's kind of
important to go into a little bit about
the package layering involved in the
android framework specifically in
bridgit versus android app now Android
dot widget is really kind of designed to
hold all the mechanism for your UI that
means that this is all the stuff that
shows state to the user and things that
reports user interaction events back to
other higher-level portions of your app
and really that's it anything that's in
the widget package is really meant to
only do these two things whereas Android
app which is where fragments live
activities live so on and so forth
that's where your policy goes this is
what defines what state to bind to
widgets this is what defines how you
should respond to those user interaction
events and how to issue changes to your
data model anything kind of at that
layer or above no matter how you may
factor it this is kind of how it's how
it breaks down
so this also brings us to this idea of
inflatable components which is something
that comes up quite a bit since you can
inflate a fragment from a layout people
found out really quickly that you can
use a fragment to compose some of your
views together and create basically like
a custom view but with a fragment and
really some of this kind of comes in
because people start asking you know
just if this view had a lifecycle I
could as something but really you kind
of want to use that as a stopping point
and just kind of ask yourself like what
is it about this particular view
remember mechanism only that needs a
lifecycle if you should really only be
showing the
that they're given or publishing user
interaction events if the user clicks
touches or performs any other action on
the views themselves none of these
things need life cycle events to
accomplish that goal so you should
really kind of watch out and figure out
okay do you need some sort of policy
layer that sits above that this is where
fragments are really useful because you
can compose them of higher level
controls it means that they can be
self-sufficient they have their own life
cycle they know how to hook into some of
these things they need it means that
inflated attributes can actually become
fragment arguments so you can make these
things super self-sufficient and
implement cross-cutting UI policies that
you don't have to worry about in terms
of like the overarching top level parent
context this ends up being really useful
for things like I mean even just
something as simple as adds something
where you really do need to control for
a lifecycle about when a user comes and
goes perform a request out to the
network to fetch the content that you're
going to show but really you don't want
that code getting all over throughout
the rest of your application logic you
can use this for other sorts of like
independent info cards things that are
again fully self-contained and the
parent doesn't actually need to be
involved in any of the data routing from
your central repository or whatever
other sort of model you're using under
the hood in order to get that on screen
and get the user interacting with it so
one example of using the fragment
arguments for this is on screen here
this is the sort of thing that could
probably benefit from some extensions or
helpers but overall it's it's not too
bad if you define a style able to go
ahead and inflate some of those
arguments just assign the values to the
bundle set it there and then you can
route all of this logic through your
normal fragment argument handling that
appears throughout the rest of your
fragment implementation so one of the
other use cases that we found really
useful for using fragments is this kind
of app screen kind of model so where a
fragment is taking the vast majority of
the screen it's really the main content
of your app and this is really kind of
where navigation
and really kind of takes away a lot of
the rough edges of fragments so you're
just left with the architecture
component hooks and a view so in this
model it's a lot easier to move towards
a single activity out if you've listened
to Chet yesterday and this is kind of
our recommendation going forward to kind
of use activities just as an entry point
into your app and then your content the
actual things that the UI the pieces
that developer or users actually work
with are the fragments of your app right
the actual content is in fragments so
with this model the only thing the
activity needs to do is handle kind of
common app chrome so if you're using an
action bar still or if you're using like
bottom nav or a side nav these would be
good things that the activity can manage
but the rest of it can be decoupled
destinations decoupled screens all of
these fragments can be much more
independent from one another rather than
being tightly coupled together so this
allows us to kind of move a lot of
things that normally you'd have to deal
with manually into a system that we can
help you out a lot more on so for
navigation for example we're going to
give you the hooks that you need to set
up the transitions and animations needed
to transition between these screens and
it's something that can be done in
navigation rather than something you
have to do by hand of course like these
aren't mutually exclusive right you can
still add a fragment to your layout or
have nested fragments underneath these
things so it's not an all-or-nothing
kind of an approach it's just one method
that yes this larger kind of content
based fragment is still a really good
way of kind of bridging the gap between
the Android app world and the widget
world another use case that is still
super useful is around dialog fragment
again we talked about kind of the active
he showed aiya log I hope everyone
forgot that by now like I said but
dialog fragment is really kind of the
same approach where instead of it being
something that you need to manage and
make sure is visible or not visible it
really kind of helps encapsulate the
interaction between a floating UI like
if you have a really important question
to ask the user a dialog is probably a
useful case in some manner but it's also
something that we've started to see a
lot more in Android P for instance the
biometric prompt for fingerprint is now
something that is in a dialog kind of
model so this is actually something that
we found really useful and part of it is
that we can leverage some of that
instant state restoration that you get
for free as part of fragments with your
dialogue this means that you've asked a
really important question otherwise why
would you show a dialog and interrupt
the user but you really don't want that
to disappear when you resize your screen
on a pixel book or rotate your device on
your phone it's a really important
question we want to make sure that we do
some of this instant state restoration
for you at the same point like dialogues
aren't just a floating UI right there's
also bottom sheets and bottom sheet
dialog fragment specifically built
around kind of having different kinds of
floating you eyes you eyes that live
above your main content without
necessarily being just the lagged in the
background kind of traditional dialog of
your so we're really trying to get to
this point where yes using a dialog
fragment is great if you have this UI
that you really don't want to lose right
it's really important for the user you
know obviously for things that the user
could use could lose it's probably not a
dialog that you want to use it's
probably a snack bar or another approach
here
this is my favorite part about dialogue
forever
there's literally nothing more you need
to do you call show or show now for the
synchronous method and that's it
very much kind of this model where we're
going to do the fragment transactions
for you again like we don't want to be
in a model where you have to do a lot of
complicated work yourself for a dialogue
fragment you can literally just call
show and it'll do the right thing and
it'll get you back into the right state
all right so one of the other things
that people tend to use fragments for
quite a bit is managing options menus
and specifically merging some menus into
some common into a common tool bar into
an action bar that's global to your
activity so fragments support options
menus because activities support options
menus this kind of calls back to that
initial design goal where fragments had
to be able to do anything that an
activity could do and the most common
use case in this today is for calling
set support action bar for your tool bar
which then sort of binds whatever your
current context is to to a particular
tool bar within your UI now this is
really great if you have some fixed
common Chrome's so in the navigation
world if your toolbar never changes
between screens then this is really
handy because the this means that you
can populate that with whatever actions
are relevant for what's in your main
content fragment pager adapter is
another really great one that people use
this for quite a bit if the actions
change across pages then all of this is
just kind of handled for you the system
takes care of it now the alternative to
this is that you can go ahead and
directly manage the menus as toolbar
view data so most of the time today
your UIs are such that the toolbar or
other sort of menu management is really
kind of part of the content I mean this
was something that you saw back in a lot
of hollow UI is where the action bar was
always fixed common chrome but now you
have these collapsing app bar layouts
and things that are much more
sophisticated to the point we're doing
this sort of global wire up is almost
jumping through hoops that you don't
really need so don't make it more
complicated than it needs to be
if you don't have common chrome for this
then directly managing some of the
toolbars menus as view data is as simple
as this like it's a couple lines of code
there's not a whole lot to it you
inflate your menu you attach a click
listener and you can keep all of this a
little bit more self-contained rather
than having this leak out into the whole
activity options menu at that point so
one of the other things that we get
asked a lot is about testing fragments
testing fragments is a whole lot easier
than testing activities you don't have
to spin up the entirety of the world an
entire new activity with sort of the
back and forth in an instrumentation
test to the activity manager to make
this work the nice part about this is
that from quite a few years ago we've
had this glass fragment controller that
is able to drive the life cycle so you
can go ahead and you can create just a
test fragment manager test fragment
controller that can test those larger
fragment components in isolation away
from everything else that might be
happening in the activity manager we use
this pretty extensively for the existing
support library tests ourselves now we
make this possible but truth be told
this is really not the best interface
for doing it it ends up looking a little
bit like this or you could go through
some of the support library tests in
AOSP and see kind of the example of some
of the utility methods that we've set up
for this
we should really probably wrap this in
some better move to state type of method
this is one of those cases where we've
fallen into a trap ourselves of some
things possible it's maybe not great the
rest is kind of left as an exercise to
the reader and we kind of just need to
do better on this part yeah so one of
the other pieces that kind of came
alongside of fragments more from a
convenience method than anything else
were loaders a kind of precursor to a
lot of what we've done in architecture
components on doing retained infant
States and one of the things we've done
recently is actually tried to decouple
them from fragments so how do we
actually do this well instead of being
their own special thing we actually
rebuilt them on a lot of the
architecture
right using these new primitives we have
of live data and view model to kind of
make these a totally independent thing
so now you can actually use loaders in
any lifecycle owner if you model store
owner class so activity fragment if
you're building your own kind of thing
it works equally well in all of those
cases so what does this mean well it
really just means that you have the same
loader you always do but instead of
calling get support fragment or loader
manager you can just call get instance
and we'll do all the hookup for you we
know that you're in a lifecycle observer
so we know how to hook all that stuff up
for you and you really were able to kind
of cut out a lot of the stuff cut out a
lot of the custom behavior here so that
you know we can kind of rely on these
new things to give you stronger
guarantees around lifecycle so we've
talked a lot about fragments and we've
talked a lot about fragments in the past
and we've talked about fragments in 2018
but there's another question where are
we going with fragments what do we still
have to do so some of this is just
coming down to building in those
stronger guarantees trying to separate
the desired behavior things that we've
specifically set out to put in versus
incidental behavior more behavior that
has just been around for six years and
it's not necessarily something that is a
codified standard so we're trying to
move towards more of a model where you
can be very confident in exactly what's
going to happen when you're using
fragments another case is trying to do
the same thing with that we did with
loader manager in in re implementing
some of these existing api's on top of
these new primitives for example like
being able to rewrite a lot of the
internals of fragments so they're
actually using lifecycle observers under
the covers right so these kind of things
allow us to kind of make sure that all
of our components are on the same page
and really doing the same thing so a few
other things again trying to
move towards a world where we have the
correct set of signals and activity
callbacks so that any interested
component can be it that means that
fragments are not a special snowflake
anymore they're just another component
another tool in your toolbox using the
same composable hooks that you'd always
have so really trying to play well with
other components so that it's not an
either/or it's a both that we can work
together that you can use fragments
alongside other components and it just
works all right so options menus are of
course one other thing that we still
don't have a great answer for this in
terms of how we want to decouple this I
mean in a lot of ways I would like for
options menus just kind of as a concept
to be deprecated but for right now we
still need to make sure that we meet all
those same use cases for when you do
have common chrome or for when you're
paging through some different content
next one maybe there we go okay so
Android opt-out fragment manager some of
you've noticed is now officially
deprecated so no more of this kind of
behavior changing out from under you
having to design against different
variants of it this works a whole lot
better in the Android X packages and
support library before it because this
means that you no longer have to worry
about all the bugs that were fixed over
time it allows us to make larger changes
to the behavior and API please send us
your wish list for the things that you'd
like to see us do for some of this too
we are going to be over in the sandbox
area right after this so please come say
hello tell us what you'd like to see
next and thank you very much for coming
[Applause]
[Music]